to Ukraine now where Keith's mayor says
the capital has been hit by a third
straight night of Russian airstrikes
authorities there say 20 iranian-made
drones and two cruise missiles have been
shot down by the Army's air defense
systems debris from downed drones
damaged buildings and started fires in
several areas Rob McBride is covering
developments for us in the capital hello
there Rob what more can you tell us
about these strikes overnight
yeah early Thursday morning many people
in Kiev were woken up by the sounds of
explosions debris being reported in
their four districts across the city
we're in one of them this is quite close
to the center of Kiev uh the debris fell
around this apartment complex it set
fire to at least one apartment here and
blasted in the windows of many others
there's also been damage to various
outhouses as debris was falling here the
Emergency Services have been here since
the early hours and people are here
still clearing up the Ukrainian
authorities report that around 20 Shahid
drones these are iranian-made drones
were fired at Ukraine across Ukraine
overnight also two cruise missiles and
they say one iskander ballistic missile
uh where they were fired and were
intercepted but there has been damage
from falling debris two people were
injured in this complex and a couple of
others were injured elsewhere in Kiev
and this is the third night that Kiev
has been woken up by these uh drone
attacks that do seem to be time to
coincide with the NATO Summit that's
just wrapped up
and Rob now that the NATO as you just
mentioned now that the NATO Summit has
just wrapped up how is that being
assessed by Ukraine
yeah I mean Vladimir zielinski if he is
disappointed uh that he didn't get the
um the guarantee or the invitation to
join NATO straight away that he
certainly didn't show it he was a very
upbeat uh in his message he's uh
delivered his usual nightly uh address
interestingly uh the nightly address
wasn't actually issued until the early
hours of Thursday morning and it
appeared that he was delivering his
nightly address from a train Carriage so
this could well be him returning to
Ukraine overnight he said that for the
first time since Ukraine's Independence
they have been given the kind of firm uh
security foundations that they haven't
had before also um that uh welcoming the
G7 support that has been given these
security guarantees and then when it
comes to Nato membership saying that
finally any ambiguity about to whether
or not Ukraine will be a member of NATO
has been removed finishing on the very
upbeat note that yes one day we will be
members of nature data great to speak to
you thanks for the update Rob McBride in
key for us